okay for people joining this live stream
we are looking at what i think or hope
is going to be a fairly
straightforward piece of wealth and
language design to do with our hash
function
all right so
okay so we have been using strings to
represent different kinds of hash codes
and they're are famous ones like sha-256
and so on right
which are conveniently stringified
okay
but
so
there are hashes with variable length
size
therefore we cannot just come up with a
number of strings i understand i
understand so so the obvious thing to do
is to have the full specification be an
association
and the strings just be shorthands for
particular associations
okay
and why do we need any of this what why
do we need uh
so perhaps we can look at this the
second part way with um
marcus education code below
first
all right so
uh the difference from crash is that it
has a key which is a part of
an argument
and
since it's not related it can be correct
and hash cannot
okay hold on the reason hash cannot be
carried is because it has a default case
right
because it eats
i i know but it has a default one
argument form that means use the default
hash code on an arbitrary expression
yes
right
okay
okay
so
one issue is can we have something which
is a carriable version of hash
which simply takes the type
and
that
um
and that can be curry applied so to
speak curribly applied
okay so let's look at this message
authentication code
um
all right so what's the difference
between this and a digital signature
um
a digital signature is mostly for uh to
authenticate the party that is signing
and message authentication code is more
to authenticate the data though they are
pretty similar
okay so now we've also in addition to
hash we've got file hash right
yeah
okay so so a curried form of hash will
be confusing with respect to file hash
because we don't want a curried form
file hash as well
okay so we have to start thinking about
those kinds of issues right
okay so let's let's
understand so so let me look at
okay generate digital signature for an
expression with a key
okay now that has a curried form
generate digital signature has a courage
form right
yes
and
this
okay
so unlike
a hash
which we are simply representing as a
byte array is that true what are we
representing all those various hashes as
we can create different forms but right
number or a string
i'm asking what does hash do
okay right now if i say hash of blah
blah blah i'll just get a number right
okay so now if i say hash of that
comma sha
256
i get
what is that is that a number again yes
still number
always okay okay so now
when people give hashes out in the wild
they usually won't give them as decimal
numbers correct the typical way a hash
is presented is as a hex string am i
correct or am i not correct
yeah but that's the third argument like
this the other argument of hash so
that's like already there
okay all right so let's take a look at
that okay so that so what is that can it
say hex string yes it can okay
so that's
a
okay fine
so even if we were currying
okay we've got a problem here because
okay so problems with currying
operator form
problems
okay we've got a problem with
file hash
we've got a problem with the third arg
okay and we've got a problem that it
already has a one argument form but
that's the less serious problem than
some of the other ones
um
uh where should we put this
i guess this is an ild derived meeting
okay
okay
so
all right now i want to understand
generate digital signature
always takes a key
as message authentication code also
always takes a key correct
yes
ah
it cannot derive the key from the string
you would have to do like
okay
private key
okay
all right
so now what will message authentication
code return
it is essentially a hash
so
by aging key we just prevent anybody
calculating
so it's like salt
salt is a public thing and that is a
private
yeah
so wait a second so the authentication
remind me what this is used for
the message authentication code
it's when you want uh to verify that the
data is correct but you don't want
anybody just arbitrary person to check
that
only only the person who has the key
okay but so explain the protocol to me
how it's how it's used in practice
so in other words in the case of digital
signature
you've got an asymmetric key pair in
this case what do you have
just explain to me how this is actually
used what is this actually used for if i
send encrypted email am i using these
things or what
hello can you tell me what this is used
for just tell me a use case
it's used for authenticating encryption
so you would calculate this before
encrypting the message
with the symmetric key with which you're
going to be encrypting your
message and then you attach that to the
message and then you create that same
uh the message and then you send them
both to the receiver who is the only
person who is able to verify this hash
authenticated messages indicated code
and is the only person who is able to
decrypt your message
as well
so it's kind of it
it's a symmetric uh
symmetric analog of digital signature if
you wish
okay
but
you are returning something which isn't
a digital signature-like object
right you're returning just a naked
string or a hash code correct from
message authentication code is that the
idea
yeah you're doing the same as a hash
yeah just a number okay but you've got
to be very very careful here because
digital signature returns an object that
knows it's a digital signature
okay you are proposing that message
authentication code just return a naked
number or string correct
is that correct uh
yes
okay so is that the right thing
because
okay why is digital signature you know
digital signature could also perfectly
well just be
some byte array down here except that it
is useful
to store information about you know this
metadata about how what kind of a
digital signature it was right
am i making sense yes because
i know that so don't you need that same
type of information to verify the
message authentication code
um
the answer is obviously yes
yes
the answer is obviously yes
right
so
because what you want to be able to do
is here we want to be able to say verify
digital signature
okay
of whatever it is with the key right
with the private whatever it was
whichever one i didn't use public key or
whatever right correct
yeah
you don't have to specify any options
it's for the same logic why encrypted
object was used because you have this
metadata and then the decrypt function
doesn't have to have any options because
all the metadata is carried over
exactly exactly right all you have to
give is the key correct
for digital signature also the original
message for which you're trying to
verify the signatures
okay fine all right so let's walk
through the same workflow for message
authentication code
okay
ready yes
okay so just like you say generate
digital signature
right
you might say generate
message authentication code
bit long but okay let's just write this
out for now
and
presumably
you see no no no no no no no no no no no
no no no no
okay
no
this isn't properly thought out okay
look
generate digital signature
can take a pure key
right a one argument form
okay so the way it works is
it's packaging
the hashing method
into that one argument form
so in other words this
has to have
a either the form where it says key
that's applied to an expert
or
it has to have just like this one an x
become a key form
okay now you're going to say but but
what about the method well obviously
just like with this one which presumably
has multiple methods as well does it not
right
that's the method must be packaged in
with the key
making sense
no it has a default
kind so
what is packaged into the key is like
the algorithm whether it's rsa or
elliptic curve for example because the
key is completely different but things
like hashing function that is used and
uh is like something that is in like a
default thingy yeah that's fine it's
fine usually it will be a default but
but the point is if you just type in
here if you say generate message
authentication code
of
um you know of of hello
right that will use a default
that will use defaults for everything
and that key is that right
so it's like hmac sha-256 or something
right is that
right
let me just explain i know that you guys
have to specify
you have to specify the algorithm you
cannot um why
what's the default algorithm
listen guys look i'm sorry i you know
this is what i get for having done
language design for 40 years is that i
can plainly see you are going to head
for a cliff here in the way that the
currying works for this okay you won't
be able to get that to work you've
either got to have the one argument form
okay that packages the key and the
method
right as soon as you don't have that as
soon as you have the method exposed you
can't make that unambiguous relative to
the two-argument form that has the
expert in it okay
you don't package the method into the
key
uh you
so in the last whether when you
highlight it can you insert uh open and
close curl bracket before after the code
directly so there are two
so um no
no you're saying that's why you know no
no no no no no no no no look look are
you saying okay look
look we could probably get away with
something where we say key
comma
method arrow whatever
you see what i'm saying
you cannot get away with something where
you have a two argument form where the
expert is an arbitrary expert you see
but the two argument form would have to
be the thing just like digital signature
where there's an arbitrary expert
followed by some
some key specification
but for message authentication code is
like the most common uh
how do you say the standard is that the
key is just about array can be arbitrary
by the array so it's not really a thing
that is different like for rsa we need
an object for like private key and
public key because different algorithms
use something completely different for a
key for mass authentication code it's
like always a binary or well a stream
okay that's fine it's fine so what's the
issue so the issue is you say you can't
if
okay the question is is there a default
message authentication code algorithm
yes or no no really why not
well
because
they didn't settle on one it's there are
a number of things that he used
there's no way there is no
preferred choice each mark is probably
one of the popular most popular but
all right so there's no default so
you're saying
there is there's no default
yeah
another thing is that it is a function
of two arguments you should not back
into key anything it should be just a
string
or not by the way
these are alternatives up here
are these alternatives yeah
one of the reasons why we got into this
message identification called thing is
that like if you look like on top of the
notebook the agenda notebook
if oh
on top of what you had already
for generate digital signature if you
for hash to specify all those things
about length of the key and lengths of
the output
you just use a method when you try to
give that to generate digital signature
you got a double
level
included a nested association
there was one of the reasons
wait wait a minute wait a minute wait a
minute wait a minute i understand i see
that but so
this is currently supported correct
uh
when the method is just a string
if you specify it as a string
no no i'm sorry for generate digital
signature you're saying right now the
method allows a hashing method but the
hashing method is just a string but as
soon as we allow the hashing method to
be specified by an association that will
be able to go one level down and have
another level of association correct yes
okay i don't think there's a problem
with that do you think there's a problem
with that
no i don't see probably that
this is the proposal actually
okay
well there was one of the um
things that were proposed also to have
like a hash algorithm had to kind of
package it a little more
uh readable but it's just aesthetic uh
it would still be an association inside
what what's the proposal
are you you scroll up um there is a
possible proposal
whoever is like moving around or doing
something could you like not do that or
put yourself on mute or something
so okay go ahead
please yeah so uh proposal highlighted
and below that second bullet point
possible proposal
uh just below
okay
so that's introducing a new thing called
hash algorithm which i don't really
believe in i don't understand the point
other than
that we're getting ourselves out of the
box of the fact that we can't carry a
hash yeah it just packages the whole
thing into
i know but but we don't have an analog
of that in all these other cases
okay so
i mean i think the way we might be able
to get out of this
is
but it's going to be a mess because
we've also got file hash to think about
i'm saying so hash algorithm
actually packages uh all the stuff and
it is of one argument function
so we if it's stickered it's like um i
know but it doesn't can't do it with
files right
we can put it enough in the file hash in
where we where we use a string to
specify the yeah in the same place like
yeah
so
this whole this whole design is about uh
the string which we specify the hash
so whenever we use it
we should be able to use the new design
i know
all right so
the thing is
in what we've done
in cryptography we do not have a
disembodied algorithm wrapper
do you understand what i'm saying
what we do instead
is we say things like generate
you know
the algorithm itself is packaged into
the use of the algorithm yeah it's more
complicated level because yeah to make
sure that every every piece is uh
stitched correctly
okay
so you know the analog would be here
that the thing we return
will be some kind of hash object
but we don't think we need that
yeah
right we don't think we need that
but that will be the analog of what
we're
okay so first yeah so the first issue is
we would like something the first thing
we're trying to get here is we'd like a
carriable form of hash is that correct
that's the main issue up here
no we first thing we want to package
parameters into her specifications i i
know that i know that we've agreed how
to do that we know we're going to have
an association which is an alternative
to the string that's done with that
we're there with that okay
and and maybe there are some alighted
forms like this
okay
but the fundamental main specification
would be an association make sense okay
okay so we're agreed on that
now
the next question is
is there a carriable form of hash
okay that's the next thing you're trying
to address correct
okay and we don't have a good solution
for that because hash itself obviously
cannot has a as a default one argument
form
okay
yes
okay so that's that's the issue
digital signature we need
uh meta information and for hash we
don't
well once you've got the hash
it's just like here it is be happy it's
a random string it's a random number
whatever okay
now
brim
hmm
look there are a couple of things going
on here i mean the first point is that
returning a hash as a number
well convenient
for
random non-cryptographic and so on uses
of hashing
is bizarre from the point of view of
people you know doing file hashes and
things like this
yeah yeah
okay so like for cryptography we always
use the byte array as a third thing
inside for calculations and then for
people who are doing like file hash it's
usually a hex string because you just
send that as a string
right but but you know but listen i've
used hash
a zillion times where i literally take
you know i'll i'll take um
um
you know i'll do things like i'll say
mod hash
comma 100 or something
um you know which i'm doing for
just you know some totally random you
know
thing where i just want to be able to
distinguish them i'm making sense
so it's a it's a
so there are two different types of hash
in terms of
uh so in terms of users i know
cryptographically secure hashes
so what you are after is a very quick
hash it's okay if it's uh i know whereas
some people want cryptographically
secure hashes like chartered exactly yes
i understand
which gives us a certain possibility
okay
that we could conceivably have a
function called something like
cryptographic hash that works in a
different way than our just el cheapo
hash function
possibly
or secure hash probably
maybe yeah maybe a better name
because you don't use cryptographic
anywhere
okay
um
i don't really like using secure because
that's kind of signing up for the fact
that you know
it'll never be broken even in the world
of of um
whatever but
okay but in any case
we may have a little bit of wiggle room
there
okay
because i agree with you that there are
different uses
and um
i honestly think they're introducing
another function that does hashes but
just like slightly different is an
overkill
for this way that's what you're like no
no you encrypt and remove deaths out of
there i don't know
no no that's not the point it's not but
so that's the bad word right that's the
wrong word but this is not a good idea
because this
would lead one to have
crypto algorithm digital signature
algorithm etc etc etc you see what i'm
saying
that's wagging an even bigger dog
does that make sense i mean
so we need a we need a way we look we've
got a problem we've got a little bit of
a design glitch here with hash there's
not a not a not a stupid design that we
had that there's like this one argument
form of hash is completely sensible
right it's just that we're now being
bitten
by
a feature of that okay
okay
so
again all of this stuff is fine
right and
i don't think there's a problem in the
nested associations here
does anybody think there's a problem
with these
no i think that's fine
okay
so
okay
all right so now let's go back down
all right so why did we want to
introduce this hash algorithm thing
again oh because we want a curried form
of hash
it's just a wild idea of images
okay but i mean the thing that is okay
our other functions
like encrypt and so on
doesn't encrypt has a curried form right
is that true
no it does not have a curried form
well i'm not buying hashtag curried form
okay
so let's come down here and
okay if we don't worry about a carried
form here
so then it's just expert key and then
it's basically the same as hash but it
takes two arguments in the front
right
and it has no default so it has only a
three argument form
all four
what's the four arguments i like hash it
so do you want a number or a string
my time
okay
but those arguments in principle
many of those arguments could be
packaged together in an association is
that a true statement or not
um
like the third argument of hash can be
like format goes to have string
i'm sorry this can be what
so just say it again daria
the third argument
yeah the third argument of hash that is
hex string can be just a part of method
that says format goes to headsets okay
okay okay that's okay fine
so in other words you're saying that in
hash
there isn't strictly a need
by the time you've got an association as
the second argument
you don't actually need the third
argument correct in that case
that's what dario is saying dario is
saying that one of the elements in the
association
yeah i don't like that because
because
calculating the hash and specifying the
format the output format
they're different
well i don't think it matters so look do
you understand i'm not suggesting that
we remove the three argument form of
hash
i'm only suggesting and daria is
suggesting that it'd be possible to
package together which i think is a good
idea because you can pick it up and then
you've got the equivalent of the curried
form of hash
okay you've got something which which is
sort of almost as convenient in the
sense you're picking up this association
you're just sticking it in hash and then
it does the correct form of hashing
see what i'm saying
you know i think it's i think it's a
perfectly reasonable idea i don't
putting putting the return type into
what is otherwise purely a specification
about parameters of the algorithm
just so that we can get a curried form
seems like
i traded you were not paying attention
you were not i thought i was paying
attention stephen i thought i thought i
said that accurately you're saying that
you're talking about putting the return
type hex string into the association
that describes the hash algorithm yeah
and constantine is saying he doesn't
like that and i agree with that it
doesn't belong okay but it has nothing
to do with currying well i thought that
you were the only reason to i thought
that you were getting this for thought
this you know last argument out of hash
hex string so that you could curry it i
thought no
no i was saying it is the moral
equivalent of currying because it allows
you to have something which you can pick
up as a single argument and say
this is my
right the moral equivalent of courage
and fine but but i agree with
constantine that it doesn't belong in
that association that association which
is used in other places where it
wouldn't even make sense to specify a
return type
that association yeah okay that's true
okay
all right okay
okay so let's come back down here
and uh
so
you're saying there's a four argument
version of this
expert key
so now notice that encrypt has the key
first
uh
yeah it could be first i don't think
yeah that
brother should be consistent
okay
now
in the case of
really
there's a lot of examples of this where
is the
where's this oh i see that's in the
method association okay
so
in the case of encrypt
all of the detail about how it works is
in the method because there is a default
encryption
right
um
yeah
okay but here you do not want to do that
the likelihood is it's going to be
method message authentication code
comma expo yes we could have the third
argument which is algorithm
specification as automatic and we could
just assign something to it
but um
well the alternative would be
okay that first form
you know which which we would now have
as
um
that would now be key
expert
we do have it always that way round it's
always key first for all our functions
is that correct
digital signature works that way as well
is that correct
i think for signature it's actually the
other way around okay so then why
yeah that's an interesting question
ah and that has a curried form
okay so we could have it be the other
way around probably
okay what makes more sense if you were
reading this off what would you say what
would the sentence say that describes
what this is doing
the expert would be first because it's
the message urs indicating
well like with digital signatures that
right
yeah
so but i'm asking what sentence would
you say you're saying i'm generating the
message authentication code for
expert
using the key key is that correct
yes i'm asking what is the sentence that
you would use to describe this operation
no that's what
and similarly you would mostly say here
yeah okay
for x by using the specified private key
so in this case it's
generally message
authentication code forex but using the
specified key
okay
and for right now we would only support
a three argument form
in which there is an explicit message
explicit method specification which can
either be
a string
with a bunch of defaults or it can be an
association is that correct
okay
and by default this thing will return a
hex string or what
or a byte array what will it return by
default if you don't go fourth argument
uh yeah i hate to say but it should be
consistent with hash
so it would return a number an integer
really really
really yeah it's not it's not a good
idea but it should be consistent but i
don't agree with you i don't agree with
you i don't think it needs to be
hash is a function that has a one
argument form
okay that has
i mean i don't what would be the most
useful thing for message authentication
code to return i would say binary
and what will function will you use it
in
usually you package it together with the
message how it's going to store
how
um
i don't understand why we don't have
this return
an authenticated message for example i
don't know what the right name is but
something like this which has the
message in it and the code
and then when you if you want to verify
it how would you verify it let's imagine
that we had just like generate digital
signature we have a thing like this
except that with digital signature it's
just the disembodied signature whereas
here it would be the authenticated
message with its
you extract the message from this thing
and apply message authentication code
again
the same queue like with the hash yeah
with the same key
so yeah with the same key
then you will have to extract the
message no no
no constantine think about it right
think about it okay okay the problem is
that that expert right now can be an
arbitrary expert right
okay
so
although we might be able to get away
with having it be an arbitrary expert
except for one with the with head
authenticated message
okay but but then this is what you would
want presumably no you would you would
have a thing that is called verify
you know verify authenticated message
basically
correct
right with given the key just like we
have here verify digital signature with
the key correct
i think it can be easier and be more
close to hash like really
so much of message messages
authentication code should return
something we can stick back as a first
argument
into it
um
oh no no no no no
[Music]
like like you do with the hash you
calculate the hash of expression again
and you just compare the output with
what you got
yeah verify additional signature is
different because verification algorithm
is different than signing algorithm
for hashes
okay so what you're saying is
it's one way the problem is the problem
is
let's think about this in practice okay
what you want to do
let's think how people will use this
right so for example
they might want something in a notebook
which is somehow
well i don't know i mean i wish you
could
is there any way you can not have this
background noise sorry i'm just
um
the
okay
so
all right i'm asking you
you've got the message you've got the
code now you send both of those but how
do you send them in what form would you
send them would you send them as a list
as we're doing here message comma
signature
do you see what i'm asking yeah they
don't have to be attached in some
special way
i know they don't have to be i'm asking
in the actual practical usage what would
you do
you could write the code on a piece of
paper
and stick it on a bulletin board but
that's probably not what you're actually
going to do
right i'm asking in practice how will
people package these and move them
around
did you understand my question
yeah
okay so what's the answer give me a use
case for all of this
right i've got i've got
a big file
i mean i don't even know what the file
version of this looks like what does the
file version of this look like i've got
a file i want to be able to have i mean
i've got my email message or whatever
okay
and
i'm going to send it with some kind of
code right
so you just stick the well just upon
there's a
separate part you'll send a message
append is a separate what
when you send the name wheel
is just separate that goes on a separate
part
yes i know i know i it goes in
okay it's effectively an association
where part of it is the is the text the
message part of the subject line part is
this authentication code right
what is the interoperability of this
stuff with our email handling stuff
do you understand the question
yeah so it seems that this is a new
function um
um
well assume that you want to send
verified email
you would be using one of these is that
correct
or is that not correct i thought
actually with verified email i thought
you picked up people's public keys his
phone yeah
[Music]
okay so that's not relevant to verified
email is that true or is that not true
um
todd held himself here we're we're
drowning here
well unfortunately my knowledge is
supposed to get into message
authentication code
anyway like i don't think this is a
function that we're going to add in this
new version constantine right
this is just like one of the use one of
to support the things that we need more
flexibility into hash because there are
users trying to design this function
but we're more
right now
well but we might as well design it
since we're doing this you know
okay can we can we please just verify
clarify please this is not used for
verified email yes or no
is this used for verified email
not for emails no okay so what is it
used for
for example so when i click hash for
file
um what i said i'm changing your file
and i'm sending your hash or you get the
hash to verify that the file is correct
so
i don't want anybody to forge the hash
so i instead of fine i do
i don't i can collect message
authentication code
and
i use the key which we share
so in other words
no no i mean but but look this is the
case where you assume there's a secure
channel for the key is that correct
yeah
okay but there is an insecure challenge
beforehand
right so as opposed to the public key
case
where you can send something which can
be verified only by the receiver
from their private key because they
publish that public key and you but the
advantage here well i don't really know
what the advantage here is because the
sender and receiver have to have agreed
on the key correct
okay
so in practice
like when people use
a checksum for a file for example
or a hash for a file
the difference i don't even know now
technically i'm now i'm confused what
the technical difference is
okay what else are we doing in addition
to just hashing the file we've got a
hash of the file what is this hmac part
of it doing that's a that's some kind of
key derivation function isn't it
what does hmac do on top of the sha-256
it come by it calculates sha and
combines it in
in a way that it cannot be forged
that combines it combines it with water
it prefixes
with specific things and then
so when you say it can't be forged
you're saying i mean it is the case that
given that key i can go back to the
message and i can regenerate whatever
that
uh mac code is right
as long as you have as the message and
the key yes
right okay so could you explain again
what does the hmac part of this do
so i can generate the hash
from the expert and the key i can
generate
oh i see i see i see i see no no no no i
get the point the point is that the hash
is generated purely from the expert
there's no key involved what the hmac
part of it is doing is is
tangling the key up with that hash
exactly yeah
okay
okay i get it
okay
okay
well and your contention is
that in practical uses of this
that i would have on a separate channel
i would send the key information
so that the only thing you're sending is
well you're sending the message and
you're sending the this uh message
authentication code
is that right
it's like in the same workflow like you
would send an encrypted message only
that this encrypted message can also be
uh checked for data integrity like with
hash but like tangled into the key
oh sorry so that so
but
why isn't the digital signature doing
the same thing
but it but this is the symmetrical
symmetric yes
okay
so this is the symmetric key case of
digital signature basically
am i right
yeah more or less so for you use uh
like public key channels like uh key
exchange channels like tls does with
public keys to exchange the symmetric
key and then you use the symmetric key
to encrypt your message but also to
calculate a message authentication code
that is
like allows you to check the integrity
of the message upon receivable
okay
so let me ask a slightly more radical
question
could we in principle use generate
digital signature
in other words
if this was known to be
a
an hmac method
would the workflow of digital signature
verify digital signature would that in
fact work
surely it would
yeah it would yeah um
but then people would not really
understand it like they would look for
mac and they would not be able to find
it in our documentation because we
packaged this
segment
i mean that's a that's a detail about
how but but
i'm just trying to understand the
workflow okay the workflow is identical
to generate digital signature correct
except that when i generate the digital
signature instead of providing
a private key here i provide a symmetric
key
well some digital signature algorithms
use hmac on the inside so i think it
gets too confusing at this point
i understand but the thing we want to do
is to make a workflow that is maybe it
has a different name but it is the same
workflow so for example if we say
you know for example let's imagine that
we say
you know
generate
let's let's imagine that this was
i mean we can't really call it
um
that would be a silly name because it
repeats the word code
but you see what i'm saying i mean would
it be called a max signature is it
always just called the code
it's just called the mac
okay well so
okay well so okay so let's imagine that
we had something which was generate mac
which is what you're calling message
authentication code here
and it takes the message
and the key
identical to generate
digital signature
right
and then i think it should be more
closer to hash
like honestly
it should be simpler than generate
digital signature world probably has
it's more closer to hash because you
calculate the hash and to verify it you
do same cue
okay
but then
hash
is giving the method as an argument but
digital signature is giving the method
as an option correct
that's the difference right you you
agree
yeah
okay so but the point you're making here
is there is no good default mac method
am i correct
actually so another name for this is
keep hash
um
i think that's obscure but the
difference um
it's
that's obscure
okay i mean i i mean i think it well
it's less obscure in terms of what it
does conceptually it's more obscure in
terms of its common usage
yeah
yeah basically the usage of the
signature is uh like a digital signature
but yeah
okay all right so again
okay
so i would think
that what is the most useful form of
message authentication code you think
it's a byte array why isn't it why isn't
it hex string
because the hex string is more
exportable than a byte array it can be a
hex string yeah
fine with that
okay
but i don't think it has to be the same
i'm sorry
yeah i prefer white array because it may
contain non-printable characters so
string ah
well a hex string doesn't contain
non-principle
okay
so what we're saying is
the default
would look like this it'd be a three
argument function
that would by default return a hex
string
and
like
hash its third argument could break into
an association
and like hash it would have a fourth
argument
that gives the format of the return is
that correct
yeah okay
looks good to me
any objection to this design
which is very close to the design you
originally proposed any objection to
this design
and we do not get a courage form at this
time
i am fine with not having courage for
okay yeah
yeah
okay so reviewing then so this is
one thing we are
we'll make a bright yellow
background color here okay we've agreed
on this
and um
and we've agreed on the on the on the
breaking of um
on this turning into an association
no i'm sorry with that no no no no
yeah with the hashes
okay the hashing method
would be the same association that
occurs in the second argument of hash
yes
okay
looks good to me what what about the two
the string pair form of the name and bit
length that i already said yes i think
it's fine i'm just good
yeah i think it's fine i think this is
slightly marginal because
it assumes that the second argument is a
length but
um
to have something else
so second second part the second uh
element of the list is the science
museum
oh it doesn't assume that it assumes
that whatever the first argument is
whatever the first element of that list
is determines the form of that list so
if you need a you know
it doesn't matter it should probably be
conventionally a length
okay okay yeah that's fine
um
now i don't know what happens if i say
shaw 257
uh you should get an error
but if the hash algorithm allows that
then you'll get a result
i understand i'm asking i'm asking in
practice
for sure there are just a limited
collection of sha algorithms that are
defined correct yeah
okay is there anything that has a
continuous
value you know continuous thing defined
except maybe our default hash function
which can be modeled blake can have any
multiple of eight more or less
okay fine
yeah there is uh there are others
okay
okay
looks good to me
i mean
can we get this this um
message authentication code into
thirteen one
uh yeah you might try
not for algorithm of course but at least
one
just in terms of the name i mean
hmac seems to be
i mean this is a hash based message
authentication code isn't it so there
was cmac and now hmac but now they came
up with black two
which is which works differently and
it's preferable but they didn't settle
okay all right so so i'm just clarifying
the name message authentication code is
the right name
um
we may want to have a wrapper or not
there's no
there's one name we're getting one name
here no rappers one name okay okay why
is there a rapper no i say i meant that
if you later we may decide that all hash
should should be
not an integer but some object
uh but then unfortunately we already
used methods of message authentication
called for function
something like that but
unlikely but i see i understand what
you're saying
right so the the return value
would be
that we would want a return value like
digital signature
yeah
should we call generate message
authentication code
which kind of thinking it should be yeah
that's what i proposed earlier
message authenticate
no
because it's not doing it's not
authenticating the message it's just
generating code
actually
is quite a popular and understood name
but you may not like it but um
if you say
well i mean keyed hash is nice in terms
of it being more general
i i worry about the name message because
it's like well it isn't a message it's a
piece of data you know it's a it's a um
you know biometric signature it's a
whatever you know not a message you go
right so that's the message
authentication code actually indicates
the use but in fact it is a kit hash so
if you you know
i mean i like that i like that i think
that's a better i mean in terms of in
terms of being able to find mac
you know if people look up so long as we
have reasonable search and documentation
if you look up mac or h mac or c mac or
whatever else it is
that should lead you immediately to
keyed hash
well i mean key hacks are the usages
right
so an interesting question for keyed
hash given its name
is whether it is expo first key second
or whether it is key first an x per
second
decision i'm trying to see what it's
more standard for like you know
for having a dysfunction
fine i i would tend to think given the
name keyed hash
that the key should come first
because it's saying
you know
it's all about keying that's why it's
got the name keith hash
um
all right
i look here hash is a good idea it's a
better name
and you think it should return you still
you're still going to have a return a
hex string
and not some sort of object
yes there's no reason for it to return
an object
it's not um
uh
not an integer
i'm wondering about that yeah
but i don't i don't like the integers
output but yeah here we go
i think we can get away with returning a
hex string because i think that the use
case here
is so
look hash has a use case
oh by the way it'll never be in this
form it'll always be key expo method
right
and we can kind of make the claim
that um
that you know there's a well you can't
really make the claim
you know we should have made the
convention that hash
if you give an explicit method returns a
hex string
but we didn't do that
i think it is pointless to return an
integer here
okay do you agree
like that's never what people are gonna
want
yeah
yeah okay
all right this looks good
okay
it wasn't quite as simple as one might
have hoped but is it ever
is it ever right i know these are always
complicated that's why and you know the
trick is to not make a mistake right
um
all right we'll we'll see it again when
it's implemented
and uh
okay anything else to talk about here
nope okay thanks